>> GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
TUCKER CARLSON.
HAPPY FRIDAY.
IF YOU HAVE BEEN LIVING IN
AMERICA OVER THE PAST YEAR YOU
DEFINITELY HAD THIS EXPERIENCE.
YOU WAKE UP ONE MORNING AND
REALIZE THAT SOME INSTITUTION
YOU GREW UP WITH, A GROUP YOU
ONCE LOVED AND TRUSTED IS
SOMEHOW CHANGED COMPLETELY.
IT'S NOT WHAT YOU REMEMBERED
ERIC UNRECOGNIZABLE.
IN FACT, IT'S NOW INSANE.
IT HAPPENED TO THE SCHOOL YOU
WENT TO AND MAYBE THE CHURCH YO
GREW UP IN OR CHARITY YOU HAVE
LONG SUPPORTED.
THEY ARE VERY DIFFERENT.
IF YOU ARE EPISCOPALIAN YOU KNO
EXACTLY WHAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
IF YOU GET IN TO THE SIERRA CLU
AND PROTECT THE SIERRAS, YOU GE
IT TOO.
EVERYWHERE IN THIS COUNTRY
FORMALLY RESPECTABLE
ORGANIZATION SEEM TO HAVE GONE
OFF THE DEEP END.
HAVE YOU LISTEN TO NATIONAL
PUBLIC RADIO RECENTLY?
NPR WAS ALWAYS A LITTLE NUTTY,
BUT IN A FAMILIAR,
NONTHREATENING KIND OF WAY.
THE PUBLIC RADIO STATION RAN
NICHE CULTURAL PROGRAMMING MOST
OF THE TIME.
THE CELTIC MUSIC HOUR OR
BLUEGRASS SHOW.
FOR DECADES PUBLIC RADIO'S MOST
POPULAR FEATURE WAS SOMETHING
CALLED CAR TALK.
REMEMBER THAT?
A SHOW WHERE TWO ITALIAN
MECHANICS FROM BOSTON ARGUED
ABOUT THE RELATIVE MERITS OF
FUEL INJECTION.
THEY GAVE YOU FREE ADVICE ON HO
TO FIX YOUR HONDA.
AND THEN IN THE MORNING ON DRIV
TIME ALL NPR STATIONS AIRED THE
NEWS FROM WASHINGTON.
THERE WAS THE MORNING EDITION I
THE MORNING.
THERE WAS ALL THINGS CONSIDERED
ON THE TRIP HOME.
AND TIMES NPR ANCHORS WERE LEFT
AND CENTER, OBVIOUSLY, BUT MORE
THAN ANYTHING THEY WERE
SELF-CONSCIOUSLY UPMARKET.
THEY SPOKE IN COMICALLY STILTED
VOICES DESIGNED TO SUGGEST DEEP
ADDITION.
YOU CAN IMAGINE A LOT OF SPARE
TIME AND HAVING COMPLICATED
OPINIONS ABOUT WINE.
THIS IS NPR, THEY WOULD SAY,
NATIONAL PUBLIC RADIO.
IT WAS ALL PRETTY AMUSING AND
EASY TO MOCK.
IT WAS BASICALLY HARMLESS.
NPR DIDN'T CALL FOR VIOLENT
REVOLUTION OR DENOUNCE WHITE
PEOPLE AS DEMONS.
THAT DID HAPPEN ON SOME RADICAL
STATIONS LIKE PACIFICA, BUT NOT
AT NPR.
THEY ARE DOPEY, SELF-IMPORTANT
LIBERALS.
THE KIND OF DANGLING EARRINGS
AND COMPOSTING BINS IN THEIR
YARDS.
NOT ANYMORE.
YOU HAVE TO LISTEN TO NPR NOW.
ACTUALLY, DON'T LISTEN.
WE PULLED THE CLIPS FOR YOU.
KEEP IN MIND THAT WHAT YOU ARE
ABOUT TO HEAR IS ENTIRELY REAL
ALL OF IT AIRED ON NPR OVER THE
LAST FEW WEEKS.
FIRST UP IS A SEGMENT ABOUT
DIETING.
THAT SEEMS LIKE A SENSIBLE TOPIC
.
OF US LEAVE THE COUNTRY COULD
USE SOME HELP DROPPING WAIT
PARTICULARLY WITH COVID IN THE
AIR.
NPR DOESN'T RUN STRAIGHT FORWAR
SEGMENTS ANYMORE ON ANYTHING.
IT NEVER OCCURRED TO THEM TO AI
A FEATURE ABOUT HOW TO RID
YOURSELF OF EXTRA CHRISTMAS
POUNDS.
NO.
A SEGMENT LIKE THAT WOULD BE
RACES.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH EQUIT
OR MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES.
INSTEAD, HERE'S HOW NPR
APPROACHED DIETING.
LISTEN.
>> I AM A CHINESE-AMERICAN NON-
BINARY PSYCHOLOGIST AND SHE
SPECIALIZES IN EATING DISORDER
GENES WITHIN MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES IN THE BAY AREA.
THEY SAY THE DIET CULTURE IS
EYE-OPENING.
AND ALSO UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> DECOUPLING FROM DIET CULTURE.
ARE YOU FOLLOWING ME?
YOU CAN'T EVEN HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITHOUT CERTAIN
PREREQUISITES.
IF YOU TALK ABOUT DIETING ON NP
YOU'RE GOING TO NEED A
CHINESE-AMERICAN NON-BINARY
THERAPIST AND PSYCHOLOGIST AND
BEI CONSULTANT TO DO IT.
A MERE NUTRITIONIST WILL NOT CU
THE MUSTARD.
THE NEW RULES AT NPR.
COME TO THINK OF IT, DON'T TALK
ABOUT DIETING AT ALL.
DIETING IS RACIST.
IT'S PART OF WHITE SUPREMACY
CULTURE.
HERE IS NPR'S EXPLANATION.
>> SABRINA IS A PROFESSOR OF
SOCIOLOGY AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IRVINE AND OFFERS A
BOOK, THE RACIAL ORIGINS OF FAT
PHOBIA.
FOR EXTENSIVE RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT FAT PHOBIA IS SO PREVALENT
IN TODAY'S SOCIETY WITH LARGELY
A PRODUCT OF TWO ELEMENTS
WORKING TOGETHER TO ANOINT
EUROPEANS AS SUPERIOR TO ALL
OTHERS.
THE THING IS THE VMI WAS NEVER
MEANT TO MEASURE INDIVIDUAL
HEALTH.
AGAIN, IT WAS BASED PURELY ON
STUDIES OF WHITE MEN.
>> CAN YOU BELIEVE ANY OF THIS?
HERE IS NPR, NATIONAL PUBLIC
RADIO, TELLING YOU THAT YOUR
WEIGHT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
YOUR HEALTH.
IT'S DECOUPLED AS THEY MIGHT SA
FROM YOUR HEALTH.
IF YOU THINK OTHERWISE YOU ARE
ENGAGING IN FAT PHOBIA.
THAT MEANS YOU, MR. AMERICAN,
MUST IGNORE THE COVID NUMBERS,
THE NUMBERS THAT SUGGEST BEING
OVERWEIGHT IS A MAJOR RISK
FACTOR FOR DEATH.
THE BIGGEST FACTOR IS AMONG THE
YOUNG.
KEEP IN MIND THE STATISTICS ARE
FOR WHITE MEN.
THE REAL PROBLEM WITH BEING FAT
SAYS NPR IS THAT YOU ARE
CONSTANTLY BEING OPPRESSED BY
RACIST DIET CULTURE.
>> A LOT OF THEIR PERSONAL
WRITING FOCUSES ON NAVIGATING
AIRPLANES, RESTAURANTS, MOVIE
THEATERS.
WE MIGHT CONSIDER BASIC
ACCOMMODATIONS, BUT THAT ONLY
SHOWS US HOW MUCH DIETING-
>> WE WOULD LOVE TO GET TO
EXPLAIN WHY THE SIZE OF DOORWAY
IS RACIST.
THESE ARE EXAMPLES OFF OF NPR.
NO.
THAT'S A REPRESENTATIVE SAMPLE.
WHAT YOU ARE HEARING IS AN
APPROACH.
YOU COULD HAVE ACTUAL REPORTING
ON ACTUAL TRENDS OR STORIES THA
RELATE TO YOUR AUDIENCE AND HAV
SOME INHERENT MEANING.
NO.
NPR HAS DECIDED ONLY TO COMPLAI
ABOUT FRIVOLOUS QUESTIONS.
LISTEN TO THIS SEGMENT IN WHICH
NPR'S NEWS DIVISION INFORMS US
THAT HOUR LONG NATIONAL
NIGHTMARE IS FINALLY OVER.
THANK GOD.
SESAME STREET HAS FINALLY HIRED
IN ASIAN-AMERICAN PUPPET.
WATCH.
>>> THIS YEAR THE SHOW WELCOMES
A NEW CHARACTER, ELECTRIC GUITA
PLAYING JI YOUNG, THE FIRST
ASIAN-AMERICAN MUPPET IN ITS
HISTORY.
>> IT WAS ACCELERATED WITH THE
RISE IN HATE CRIMES AGAINST
ASIANS THIS YEAR.
>> THE RISE IN HATE CRIMES
AGAINST ASIANS COMMITTED BY ALL
THE TRUMP SUPPORTERS.
THAT SPURRED SESAME STREET TO
GET AN ASIAN MUPPET AND SPURRED
NVR TO CELEBRATE IT.
THIS IS A BIG CHANGE.
IF YOU REMEMBER SESAME STREET
THERE WAS A BIG BIRD COOKIE
MONSTER.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE ETHNICITIES.
THAT WAS THE POINT.
THERE WAS NO TRIBALISM ON SESAM
STREET.
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE ANIMALS, NO
PEOPLE.
NOT ANYMORE.
ACCORDING TO NPR'S THE ETHNICIT
OF THE SESAME STREET MUPPETS IS
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING.
AND NOT JUST ON SESAME STREET.
ON ALL ENTERTAINMENT AND ART AN
CULTURE.
NPR DOESN'T READ BOOKS ANYMORE.
THEY HAVE THROWN IT DOWN.
THEY DO STREAM A TON OF GARBAGE
OFF THE INTERNET.
WHEN THEY WATCH IT, THEY ARE
MOST INTERESTED IN WHAT THE
PEOPLE LOOK LIKE.
THE SHAPE OF THEIR SKIN.
HERE IS AN NPR PRODUCER
EXPLAINING WHAT HE HAS BEEN
WATCHING.
>> WHAT TV SHOW WHERE YOU
BINGING THIS YEAR?
>> I WAS WATCHING VR LADY PARTS.
IT'S A MUSICAL COMEDY ABOUT A
PUNK BAND IN LONDON MADE UP OF
ALL MUSLIM WOMEN.
>> IT'S A MUSICAL COMEDY ABOUT
PUNK BAND IN LONDON THAT IS MAD
UP OF ALL MUSLIM WOMEN.
OKAY.
I GUESS THERE'S NOTHING WRONG
WITH THAT, BUT EVERY STORY IS A
STORY ABOUT A MUSICAL COMEDY IN
LONDON ABOUT A PUNK BAND OF ALL
MUSLIM WOMEN.
THE PROGRAM IS LIKE A I
GENERATED.
THAT'S ALL NPR NOW.
LISTEN TO THIS QUESTION THAT TH
PERSONALITY ASKED ABOUT THE
MATRIX.
>> HAVE YOU SEEN THE LATEST
MATRIX FILM?
>> I HAVE, INDEED.
IT'S WONDERFUL.
>> ANY ADDITIONAL TRENDS OR
ALLEGORIES IN THE FILM?
IS THIS SOMETHING THAT IS BEING
LEFT BY THE FIRST THREE?
>> IF YOU ARE RUNNING A NEWS
ORGANIZATION OBVIOUSLY ONE OF
THE CRITICAL QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
TO ANSWER IT FRONT IS HOW MANY
ALLEGORIES ARE THERE IN THE
MATRIX?
NPR IS DOING THAT.
WE COULD GO ON AND ON.
WE COULD PLAY YOU NPR'S COVERAG
ABOUT THE COLONIZING HAIR SALON
AND A LOT MORE.
WE WILL STOP BECAUSE IT'S
TIRESOME AND THIS IS AN NPR.
IT IS STILL NOT ENOUGH FOR NPR'
OWN HYPER EMPLOYEES.
NATIONAL PUBLIC RADIO HAS BEEN
SO THOROUGHLY RADICALIZED IT'S
ON THE VERGE OF DESTROYING
ITSELF FROM WITHIN.
CRYSTAL FLEMING, A SOCIOLOGIST
PRESENTING THIS STUDY RELEASED
THIS ASSESSMENT OF NPR'S TOXIC
WHITE SUPREMACY.
QUOTE, THE PROBLEM AT NPR IS
SO IF YOU ARE SAYING THIS
EXPLICITLY.
BY THE WAY, NOTICE THE PASSIVE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE SENTENCE AN
THE WORD INDEED.
SIGNIFIERS ARE JUST LIKE YOU, S
YOU KNOW.
A FORMER NPR CO-HOST AGREED WIT
THIS.
QUOTE, ONE THING I WANT TO POIN
OUT IS THE SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
LATINO, LATINA, LATIN
EX-EMPLOYEES WHO WORK AT NPR.
WHAT ARE WE NOW?
18.5% OF THE U.S. POPULATION,
BUT ONLY 7% OF NPR.
NOT A GOOD LOOK.
HOW UPSET ABOUT THIS CAN YOU BE?
THE REVOLUTION ALWAYS EATS
ITSELF.
IN NPR'S CASE IT'S HARD TO WEEP
ABOUT THAT.
HEARS THE DEEPEST IRONY OF ALL.
THIS IS WHAT YOU WILL ENJOY THE
MOST.
NPR SPENDS ALL THIS TIME
PRACTICING WHITE SUPREMACY.
PRIVILEGED WHITE PEOPLE ARE NPR
'S CORE AUDIENCE.
THEY ARE THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO
LISTEN.
WE CHECKED THE AUDIENCE NUMBERS.
HERE'S WHAT THEY ARE.
NPR'S AUDIENCE IS 84% WHITE.
WE DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
THAT.
WE DON'T HATE WHITE PEOPLE AND
ARE NOT RACIST UNLIKE NPR.
BUT FOR COMPARISON, THAT'S HIRE
THAN THE NUMBERS AT FOX NEWS.
NPR IS ALWAYS CLAIMING THAT FOX
NEWS IS SOME KIND OF WHITE
SUPREMACIST ORGANIZATION.
FOX NEWS IS SIGNIFICANTLY LARGE
BLACK AND A MUCH LARGER HISPANI
AUDIENCE THAN NPR HAS.
BOTH OVERALL AND AS A PERCENTAG
OF VIEWERS.
WHO DOES LISTEN TO NPR?
WE KNOW EXACTLY WHO LISTENS TO
NPR.
SHE TAUNTED YOU FOR NO REASON.
SHE WAS MARRYING A MASK AND HER
SUBARU.
THE PICTURE IS ON THE SCREEN
RIGHT NOW.
THE QUESTION IS DO PEOPLE LIKE
HER REALLY NEED MORE THAN
$100 MILLION IN FEDERAL
SUBSIDIES EVERY YEAR WHICH IS
WHAT PUBLIC RADIO STILL GETS FO
SOME REASON.
PROBABLY NOT.
BUT THAN AGAIN MAYBE SO.
WHO ARE WE TO JUDGE?
ANGRY BARREN SUBARU DRIVERS WIT